chaos on the las vegas strip tonight
after a fight at circus circus
leaves dozens running thank you so much
for joining us tonight at 11 o'clock
i'm sasha loftis this comes just one day
after a fight at a loftland casino left
one person dead
madison kimbrough joins us live outside
circus circus tonight with the latest
madison
sasha earlier this area was filled with
police activity as a fight broke out
inside of circus circus which you can
see the hotel is behind me
now we spoke to people who were ducking
under tables as the commotion was
underway
these videos were taken tonight by
viewers who witnessed the heavy police
activity
from outside of the hotel and also the
swarm of people who quickly ran from the
premises
at one point metro received information
that a person was waving a gun around
someone also reportedly yelled gun
during that fight
when officers arrived on scene they say
no gun was recovered
and they found no shots were fired still
no word on how many people were involved
and no one was hurt so as you can see
things appear to be back to normal here
at circus circus now
this is a developing story so of course
stay with 8 news now
on air and online for the latest details
reporting live madison kimbrough
8 news now